today is a very important holiday
honoring a great American leader dr.
Martin Luther King jr. this this icon of
the civil rights movements especially
relevant these days when hateful
rhetoric and the forces of intolerance
once again threatened Reverend King's
dream of a society where people are
judged not by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
well that's why today I hold hands with
my african-american brothers and sisters
to honor his struggle because as dr.
King said freedom is never voluntarily
given by the oppressor it must be
demanded oh there he goes again
what does this walking string of
store-bought spaghetti know about the
black experience and so white he thinks
a fist bump is a skin condition he makes
Mike Pence look like Malcolm X what does
Conan know about Martin Luther King
other than telling his GPS to avoid
streets with that name one time Kony
came up to me and said I love hip-hop I
have all their albums he thinks black
lives matter is a new Ben and Jerry's
flavor his favorite black actor is Lego
Batman Cohn is so scared of black people
if a commercial for Empire comes on TV
is burglar alarm goes off hey Conan I
have a dream that after 20 years of
working here you finally learn my name
you vanilla cupcake dipped in mayonnaise
and served on a j.crew catalog out by
those streaming
Fitri Paul man time thank you so much
thank you Wow
that's good for another really Wow
you